[Music]
okay so let's start hi everyone thanks
for joining us today and I'm so excited
to be here with you today we're from DNA
which is one of the largest game
publisher in Japan and today we are
going to share our implementation on
gaming so far we have released to AI
applications and we're going to talk
about the motivation and the
implementation and the outcomes of these
projects my name is Jim Ernesto and I'm
leading this project also let me
introduce each Tanaka he's a data
scientist and built our models in this
part
both of us were present so to be you is
this work has been accomplished by for
machine learning engineers and a lot of
collaborators from gaming team each of
us our own area of expertise and I
really love this team so they start I
think most of you are not so familiar
with DNA our company is one of the
largest Internet company in Japan
although we have various business
domains such as game automotive and life
science on sports most of the rain comes
from games actually we're providing
dozens of in-house game titles and other
publishers titles and maybe some of you
may know that we have an alliance with
Nintendo for example our company is in
charge of the parking system of Super
Mario run so this is who you are so
intercessions we will talk we focus on
the house game title octane o Soniya so
first I'd like to talk about the program
we had and how we challenge to solve
these issues so this game jock day o
Soniya is a strategy up game the players
action is based on the board game called
author or reverse e and the player
put black on white pieces alternatively
and what is unique about this game here
is that each piece has its own skills
which had strategic components to the
bottle actually when you start a play in
the game there are parties of play stars
and the entire endless exploration is
required to master the game so this
title was released three years ago and
the fortunately it's still growing we
have more than 24 million dollars so far
and the service region is expanding
gradually of course I hope in the future
we can release it in the US as well so
in awe sironia there is the concept of
text and characters so before starting
the bottle player a construct deck which
is composed of 16 characters among more
than 3,000 options and each characters
had its own skills and the players have
to choose consistent chapters according
to their play styles as you can imagine
the number of the combination is extreme
and it's it it's very hard for [ __ ]
to learn how to build optimal decks
another issue here is that building an
optimal deck requires two long effective
strategies through the process of trial
and error so let me explain why this is
a problem so generally speaking if the
game is complex game has complex
features which can distract players from
continuing the game the churn rate
increases and impacts the future revenue
right and for example there's a nice to
mention that just a few points decrease
in the 30-day generate can increase the
revenue by 20 to 30 percent in the
future so back to Sonya we actually have
a high Chum rate so we have a trouble
here and this is partly because the game
is complex and lacks sufficient Oh
Bernie support
and therefore it's hard to foreigners to
construct the optical deck all right so
also there is a problem that they don't
have a good place for practice in order
to improve their play skills for
instance we only have two bottle options
for [ __ ] wine NPC bottle which they
battle against very very weak opponent
and the other is a PvP battle which they
are frequently matched against a very
skill or experience players so we needed
in opponent that whose play level is
similar to the winners so here's our
approach to support [ __ ] we have
provided two functions the first one is
the deck recommendation system which
selects appropriate characters from
players piece books and we are using
Association analysis to provide a better
recommendation the second one is the
bottle AI which we call AUSA Lunia dojo
and in these functions we have developed
AI that can play at any levels a deep
neural network is used for DCI later he
will explain how these techniques are
used in our cases okay so by the way
from the machine learning perspective we
need to provide prepared data to build
such a eyes we are creating various
kinds of in-game data since the release
of the game such as tech logs and battle
logs so we had a good amount of data
when we started this project and in our
cases we used data for the last nine
masses which contains billions of log
entries then we filter the data by
players skills and augmented the
original data in the battle area cases
the image on the right side is an
example of battle logs which is
formatted in JSON and
describes interstate and action
information of the bottle and the bottom
diagram shows rough data pipelines and
bigquery did a very good job at this
pre-processing phase for instance it can
handle even terabyte order of data very
fast and we could reduce the processing
time drastically big you could handle
our data in a few minutes and well
compared with Ione Prem how to Hadoop
clusters that took like an hour so yeah
we are very very happy here and we also
love that BQ is easy to collaborate with
an other GCT services and here I want to
stress that the array has been
successfully built by sufficient amount
of data and the reliable pipeline so
let's see how this how each of these use
cases works this is a rough overview of
the accomodation system so we first
exploit purposes deck logs to extract
information about how each characters
are associated which we call Association
rules with this analysis we can score
the strengths of the relationship across
the old Apparel's chart chapters if
there is a request from the player the
recommendation server responds I mean
the set of receive data set of
characters in the players base box and
it fills all the 16 characters according
to the score of Association rules the
function this function is very flexible
and the player can specify that
archetype and the cost and also the
favorite chapters to be included in the
deck
regarding KPIs that we're monitoring
several metrics for instance we're
watching how many players have used this
recommendation system and whether the
recommended deck has been accepted or
whether the deck contributed to the
players in terms of win rate at battles
asked us for the dojo player can battle
against AI with spurious archetype
Sunday strength so here we trained a
deep neural network from pre-processed
but logs the clients and current the
game status and the bottle API server
returns the inference of new networks at
every turn of the bubble and the apps as
for the matrix we're monitoring how
frequently that dojo is used for [ __ ]
and whether the strength of AI was
sufficient internals win rate so these
two guys have already been released and
the we observing plotted the KPIs and
before showing the results I want to
pass the talk to Ikki and he'll talk
about technical details and some tips
for building AI hi everyone I'm Miki and
the data scientist at DNA so I'm one of
the developers that created our gaming
system by using machine learning and
data science so today I will talk about
the technical details of our use cases
with TCP so now let's look at the story
of the technical part first I'd like to
start by the tech recommendation this is
ultra of the document the algorithm
faster is the algorithm receives some
input from a prayer such as a tech
archetype that cost the possessed
characters and characters the player
wants to use next algorithm select a
leader by using the result of
Association analysis and statistical
data in this algorithm the leader
character is chosen first and the next
character is next characters are
secretary based on the leader the
associated characters are selected
simply simply selected based on the
result of Association analysis if the
deck is not have 16 characters the
another character is circular to base
the character as a base character
after repeating this procedure several
times the recommend deck is proposed to
the prayer if the game is different the
way of fine tuning is also different in
a game cocktail sironia for example we
made additional rules to decide a leader
and we ignore the characters who the
skill will be never activated in the
deck a directive gives a brief
explanation about how to extract the
relationships between characters in our
recommendation we are using the
Association and nurses the Association
Isis is is is a rule-based machine
learning method for discovering
meaningful relations between contents in
large dataset
this method can perform high-speed
calculation to extract some many rules
and extract relations are easy to
understand and useful in various
settings the relations are evaluated
with some metrics exact like the
strengths of the connections and
frequency of the rules and patterns our
recommendation with the deck by
selecting the character sequentially
with strong relationships one after
another this method can handle the
various kind of data easily so this
technique is applicable to many games
and other fields next I will talk about
the system so we with our applications
like the clock the commendation and
divining a bot with TCP so why did we
choose this EP for machine learning
systems there are two main reasons the
first one that the DCP has powerful and
flexible tools for machine learning and
data science in the data analysis we
often try to investigate the data
visualize it and create the prototype
models the disapear services for the big
data analysis make it possible for us
such as bigquery equal data lab and
Google compute engine and the crud of
storage provides a scalable and the
fastest
service for large data and it helps and
it helps us to manage l managed cervical
data and a lot on machine learning
models about Krauthammer engine this we
we can replace air models to create a
machine learning engine easily and
quickly and it also provides a
user-friendly api's additionally
disappear by the many services for to
perform the machine learning efficiently
for example we are using we are trying
to use gk control service and quad range
in training with custom functions for
scarab and distributed table trainings
ii wise that the DCP has scalable and
robust infrastructure services we can
run applications easily by using google
app engine with several programming
languages like Python and code language
and we can check many metrics truck
driver logging and others a direct
emphasis that the auto scaling of the
Google App Engine it's very well
serviced because new instances are
increased was stopped in response to
traffic and request are distributed to
the instances automatically these
disappear services are easy to integrate
into the same system moreover also I
don't touch on the product details
Google Cloud brings many advantages to
our business like the security equation
and openness for these many reasons we
are choosing DCP for Emeril systems next
I will show the system shows us I will
show the system architecture of the
documentation with DCP that the clocks
are saved in bigquery which are used to
extract the rules we set across
scheduled to perform about processing of
the association analysis in Google
compute engine and in order to catch up
the trendex with latest characters we
are performing the
processing everyday the include
functions processes result Association
analysis and appraise the data for
production environment in GCS call the
function checks if the data is a plated
correctly for example is the dead sizes
too small or large then we are using
Google App Engine Python 3.7 for Luca
MIDI API server the server receives a
request from the client then build a
deck using analyzer data in the final it
returns a recommended deck to the prayer
one of the notables point is that GE
Python 3.7 was generally available at
the end of last year so we could use it
just at the right time as a result of a
played to Python 2.7 we didn't need to
change our code that we had already
developed in Python 3 so I've explained
the algorithm and the system with a
recommendation let's move on to the next
topic departing Airport it's called
Australia dojo dojo means our training
room to improve playing skills this is
overview the training in differently but
the planning was suitable for a case too
many complicated features such as state
of the export hands status and the
combination of the features the tip
planning have both receives a receives a
state of battle from the client the
informational battle is converted to the
numerical features which is which which
are used as the inputs of the d-brane
here we created more than 5000 features
the network learns the actions of top
tier players as binary classification
finance the different model outputs the
values of each action that will be used
to decide an extraction
we used more than 10 million butter
records in the training in our training
we are using the battle record of highly
skilled players but we needed to
increase the AI with appropriate skills
for beginners in order to devise the
strength of AI into multiple levels we
are processing the inference results
specifically we insert the highest
iteration value when we want to make a
strong AI and we wanna weaken the
strength of AI we select the second
worst our values with a probability
technical is ability is calculated by
softmax function which transforms the
values into the gravity distribution
after tuning of probabilities we made
five levels of AI in the latter part we
will show the remarkable results of the
winning rate against the actual players
next I will show the system of a about
first of all I talk about of training
phase a large number button records in
philippi is saved in cold storage
through bigquery the training process
consists of the pre-processing of the
features and module training which are
running in Google compute engine as the
pre-processing the features are
generated on demand by emitting the game
in our case we created the custom
function of data generator that creates
the features during the training after
the training the trainer model is saved
in crud of switch to deploy on to the
Quadrangle engine
regarding the contrast integration and
delivery of machine learning it's
so-called clcd
we are testing and training modules to
check the dependencies and features
automatically by using the unit tests
will regression test also it is
important to deploy a model
automatically in short cycles with high
reliability we're releasing new
we are currently trying to simplify a
complicated process from training to
deployment by using CSC detours for
executing it more quickly and easily I
think we can leverage a crowd build the
contrasted every service of DCP to
accomplish better CCD I move on to the
inference phase please take a look at
the communication between the client and
the inference a peer server on the left
of the slide the bottle records are
posted to the inference API server from
the client who is praying against the
airport - serious server he produces a
bottle from the record they extract the
features and it sends the features to
the only prediction API of the cloud
every engine on a prediction of credible
engine is very useful because it is
optimized to run the air model with low
latency in your time Kodama engine uses
the trainer model store the included
storage and the return the values of
each action the values are sent back to
the client and the client moves for the
butter step by selecting the best action
according to the values that's the
overall communication between the client
and server appengine and crud Amira
engine can auto scale in response to the
traffic not a very good function by
taking the benefit of the auto scaling
we can manage a large amount of requests
last we are touching on the technical
topic the testing of the systems so why
should we test the systems I mentioned
in the last write the code ml engine can
auto scale that's good
is that true but we didn't have enough
knowledge about how much load the system
can withstand in the mobile game
generally the Lord tends to increase at
the moment a new event opens the thing I
was right shows the example system
that estimated requests per second in a
realistic event this is a trial
calculation the requests per second will
increase to several hundreds in ten
minutes we have to check in advance if
the system can withstand like this load
as a point to be noticed we cannot
predict the action of AI as a batch
processing at regular intervals our
system has to respond to the request in
real time that is where the AI should
push the character in the next stone to
achieve this we chose only prediction of
the query engine we've checked in
Hoosick whatever engine can satisfy our
requirements by performing a lot of
testings
in advance of the release in our case
the testing was performed in the setting
of the request increased linearly and
reach a maximal 1,000 weakest per second
we found that 'scrote-meal engine can
scale quickly responds to the request
and the average latency of the
prediction is less than one second
however there were huge answer took a
longer time than usual since this might
not be possible to risk return return
all the requests to the player quickly
so we needed we needed to resolve this
condition our team and credible engine
team cooperated to investigate that
bottlenecks the dam we found found that
time what had happened when the new
instances warmed up in the process of
the auto scaling due to heavy roll it
was challenging to handle large number
requests which consists of many features
at the same time with only prediction
but if we can resolve this problem by
building an efficient back-end system we
don't have to amass the system
beforehand and system will be more
robust so our team took attempted to
deal with this problem
let's take a look at how we tackle to
remove the errors when the error returns
within the time we can simply throw it
back again to the API but in the case of
time out the system cannot send it back
again because the time error is not
returned therefore when the inference a
player server does not receive the
response within five seconds the request
is sent back to the API again because
something bad has happened in the
inference also it was a destination was
a request is the same endpoint it will
further increase the load on the server
as a result we set another backup
endpoint to receive the request that
fails to be operated in the main point
that it's a second request is sent to
the backup endpoint which is prepared
independently from the main and the
point this is a result of the lot of
testings with backup endpoint the figure
shows the total error rates of several
settings
no backup backup is Temenos and the back
of 20 million loss in the case with a
backup and a point on the left about 1.3
percent of errors remained in the middle
setting of the back up with Timmy Munoz
also small error still remained the
backup can deal with most of the main
point errors we found that reasonably
small error was because a number backup
instance was small so the tie-rod had
still happened was warm up of the auto
scaling in the backup environment the
rightmost case is fine-tuned setting
where as a number of okapi instances was
set to 24 covering the main and 0.0
errors sufficiently in this case we
could handle all the requests without
errors in this very DNA and crud arrange
engine team got over the challenge
high under spiky traffic
and the latency limit visitors after
deployment in this setting the system
has been stable in handling many
requests let me show you one more thing
it's a useful service to monitor the
system performances we can check the
server performances through stackdriver
which provides error reporting are at
notification logging threads of latency
and many others structural dashboard
especially provides a visualization tool
that is easy to add a chart and
customize it we are monitoring the many
metrics according to our needs in the
one place for example the number of
requests a PR agencies CPR the memory
usage and the number of learning
instances in your time additionally you
can change the time window to focus on
and check the percentile values we are
using 99 percentile values for anomaly
detection in the system so so far I have
explained the technical details were AI
with DCP the system with DCP can be
constructed flexibly to cope with
various problems in gaming and other
fields now I'd like to hand over to June
for the KPI result of use cases in the
future thanks
okay so this is a result part so as he
mentions we needed a scalable and robust
system to successfully reduce our a eyes
so in this final part we would like to
share what happened after the release so
first for the deck recommendation here
is a chart which shows the number of
pinners who use the key recommendations
there were constant usage after the
release but this function was not well
known at this time but the station has
been changed after we started an in-game
event to promote players to build new
decks so the deck recommendation system
has been recognized more and even after
the event has finished many players and
the mostly beginners are still using
this function frequently so second we
are very glad that the recommended tech
push the wall rates of the [ __ ] by
about 5% compared to the deck created
without the recommendation so since our
focus was to support beginners we are
very satisfied with these results also
I'd like to mention that this function
has good adoption even form top T
appears that this was sort of by product
but we are observing that heavy players
usually update their deck frequently and
this recommendation system mitigates the
cost of building deck from scratch they
use recommended recommendation as a
first suggestion and then customize the
deck as they want so let's see the
system matrix as well after the release
we have a stable latency of 20 min take
which is vecina for our cases and we're
surprised by the result because
recommended shown resumes is very
complex and we haven't expected such a
low latency so the auto scaling does a
good job
we haven't had any citizen trolls so far
so briefly we will explain about the
evaluation of the planning area but
after the release we are observing that
the our a boat has good enough win rate
as parties partner foreigners so this is
chart shows that the the win rates of AI
against players the horizontal axis
denotes the players skill levels and the
vertical axis is the win rate of AI so
in the dojo
we provide five different AI levels and
the strongest one can even be top tier
players with win rate of 50% so we think
that our a is is strong enough for
winners support so handy from [ __ ]
perspective we invest of AI ranges from
our 20% to 80% which means that the
player can choose any I mean appropriate
levels of AI according to their skills
or preferences so therefore this AI
works as a sort of good mentor although
this was a released last month and that
we don't have enough data to evaluate
the business impact
daughter is used by being very well and
we hope that this can lead good kept
here in the future and yes for Dmitry
the system matrix the inference of
machine learning engines is about 200 to
300 the music and very stable even for
the inter system the response time is
about a second which is enough fast for
our case and become by a backup end
point is working well and we don't have
system trouble so far so at the end of
my talk I will show items which worked
in our cases so first to train the AI
that play the game like a human we need
the battle logs that completely
reproduce battle status and action
so if you have some random effects in
the game make sure that the random seeds
are sore in the logs so secondly for for
the evaluation of our AI we needed to
run thousands of battles to get
performance statistics so a headless
numerator helps us a lot in this context
and well if you want to try to use brain
enforcement running techniques you also
need to very I mean the very very fast
simulator because the number of the
battle there are origin goes through
very really matters and is heard we also
want to stress that scalable and robust
system is critical for I'm implementing
AI in VR services we see that GCP in
particular called machine learning
engine and GAE who are a good choice for
us and as for the CI CD we have to think
about how frequently or by which trigger
the am older should be updated because
the game environment changes frequently
we need to keep I mean adding features
and the retraining the models after the
release so the this operation is very
heavy and we have to think about the CIC
be made before LEDs in particularly in
the amo leading phase the final item is
not technical but a critical generally
speaking we don't know how well it will
perform and how big the business impact
will be before starting a project so in
such an asset a case situation the
communication controlling the
expectation is very very important
although we are machine learning
engineers we try to understand the game
and the business issues correctly and I
think that this was a key factor of the
success of these projects so that's all
from me and I like to pass the summary
to Henry thanks
so hi everybody I'm Henry Tappan I'm a
product manager on the AI platform team
working on what was formerly known as a
cloud machine learning engine but we've
just rebranded to be the AI platform
this was a really exciting thing so
we've been working with the DNA folks
for a while for this one mostly being
inspired by the very elegant way that
they took a number of machine learning
techniques and built a awesome
experience for their beginner gamers now
when we saw this you know we we notice
there's a lot of different things that
they had to use a lot of different
pieces of technology between App Engine
compute engine the cloud machine
learning engine and so on and so forth
so the challenge to us at Google is how
could we make make it even easier for
teams like DNA or other gaming companies
to get started even faster producing
these kinds of innovative but also very
accessible gaming experiences for it
using things like machine learning and
AI so we've been working on a number of
features to make the process of getting
started that much easier and that much
simpler so one of the ones that we
noticed was starting to think more about
machine learning beyond just tensorflow
Sai kit and XG boost so cloud machine
learning engine was one of the first
cloud-based platforms that enabled you
to train a tensorflow model in the cloud
since then in the last few years we've
added support for other libraries like
scikit-learn and XG boost but especially
seeing what was done with association
rules and other data mining techniques
we realized that the world of saw and
the world and the problems are much
bigger than that which is easy to do
inside of these frameworks and so we've
been working on introducing support for
custom containers into our training
component this is now available in a
public beta we expect to go to full
release probably in this quarter but
certainly inside of 2019 we're with
custom containers you can take any code
any framework that you can stick inside
of a docker container and then push it
to the cloud machine learning engine in
the same way that you would use
tensorflow models or Sai kit or XG boost
or any other kinds of training scripts
so this gives you access to not only
traditional machine learning framework
like tensorflow pi torch cafe etc but
also to run any other software that you
might need so if you've written some C++
I'm Java codes some different Python
routines even our code for solving
certain parts of your analysis or
production of models you can now go it
go ahead and easily train them on the
cloud machine learning engine
additionally it's not shown on here but
we've also been thinking more about how
we get easier pipelines for solving some
of these things so earlier late last
year we released into the open source a
system called cube flow pipelines which
is a composition and an orchestration
engine for running machine learning
focused workloads on cube flow pipelines
you can start up a kubernetes cluster on
gke or on your own premises etc specify
a simple workflow that says all the
different steps you'd like to do on the
way including training jobs on the cloud
machine learning engine and then the the
cube flow pipeline system will take care
of doing all the steps necessary making
sure that it runs runs effectively so
this could be a great way for tackling
bigger parts of your machine learning
workflow besides just the actual
training part at the very end of it so
the second thing that that we really
inspired by and I've been working on is
I think June's on pointed out very very
well that when a nikkie as well that
when predictions come back from
predictions come back from the machine
learning framework or as you're putting
data into the system's you often need to
do other transformations to make it
compatible for the game so coming back
to the example of the AI it wasn't
enough to just get a particular score
back from the model but they also needed
to select based on the players skill
level a random choice of a different
different option in it now this was
could be really hard and that you know
you might have to set up different
servers for post-processing or pre
processing the data before you send it
to the machine learning engine so to
make this simpler we have available as
of today in beta the ability to run any
Python code on the cloud machine
learning engine prediction service
before or after you make any predictions
so if we need to reshape someday
maybe take a different result convert
from a score back into label so on and
so forth it's now just as simple as
giving us a Python class and you've got
whatever you need to make happen along
the way this incidentally also gives you
some more flexibility as well we allow
you to install any Python packages on
the inference server as well and then do
whatever you'd like with inside those
packages so you have much more many more
options for running jobs on side of our
machine learning systems and then
finally the other big advancement that
we've seen that was I think especially
relevant for gaming and one thing that
was inspired by DNA is giving better
flexibility and better capacity for it
so you know it's really great to see to
see heavy usage of our systems and we
want to make sure that we're giving you
exactly the capabilities that you need
that you are able to run your jobs
bulletproof even for when you have high
demand bursty instances for it so today
in the machine learning engine on the
prediction side you're able to choose
either a four core or a dual core
machine with a choice of RAM in there
we're expanding this range of options to
be virtually any machine type that's
supported on cloud machine learning
engine or we're sorry that's sort of
support on the Google compute engine and
including into the support for
accelerators like GPUs so that way if
you've got a job that is very intense or
very bursty or you want to maintain a
certain level of latency you're now able
to select many more machine types and
much more power to those ones especially
if those who are looking for really
complex models like reinforcement
learning or you're trying to beat the
next Starcraft AI this might be a great
option for you so let's kind of sum up
with these things this was a chance for
us to see that AI can be used for much
more than you know recognizing images or
speech or something but we can actually
use machine learning AI to create
compelling gaming experiences both to
challenge our players for you know when
we want to give them a smarter AI but
also to assist them so that beginners
have an even playing field
with those who have been on it for a
long time and the result of these kinds
of experiences can result in better
engagement and revenue
for your for your game and then finally
to know that Google cloud is here to
help we're very interested in the gaming
segment we're very interested in machine
learning so anything that we can do to
help you achieve success in your game
and we're happy to do it
[Music]